His Majesty King Abdullah the second
email Hussein and President Lee
Bollinger
good morning welcome to the world
leaders forum at Columbia University we
are honored to be joined here today by
His Majesty King Abdullah of the
Hashemite Kingdom of Jordan King
Abdullah many of us at Columbia sorry
Her Majesty Queen Rania was unable to be
here we hope she will be returning to
our campus very soon the king is
accompanied by a delegation that
includes government ministers royal
advisers and members of the Royal
hashemite Court among them mr. Nasser
jodete minister of foreign affairs for
inside bin ride Jordans permanent
representative to the united nations dr
ali abrin ambassador to the United
States and dr. Khalid Al karachi chief
of the Royal hashemite court welcome to
all of you King Abdullah we look forward
to hearing your address the Arab Spring
time to listen and act and we thank you
for coming here to our University to
share your thoughts and a subject of
such importance to the entire world the
swirl of events of the past 10 months in
the Middle East and northern Africa has
thrust upon us and historic moment
defined by uncertainty and instability a
moment of change to call these times
tumultuous hardly captures their
significance for most of us it is
difficult to avoid experiencing such
times with anything other than an
alternating mix of guarded hope and
sincere concern well we cannot know
where the events we are witnessing
ultimately will lead we can be certain
that the consequences of the popular
uprisings in the Middle East in northern
Africa will be with us for many years
and decades to come King Abdullah has
stepped to the fore to address these
fast-moving events His Majesty has
talked openly about the need to achieve
political reform and about his duty to
help lead the debate
addressing his nation in June King
Abdullah spoke of the obligation to be
quote discerning ly aware of the
difference between the required
democratic transformations and
achievable ones on the one hand and the
risks of chaos on the other the 42
amendments to Jordan's Constitution
proposed last month by a royal committee
on constitutional review and presented
to the nation by the King would
establish greater judicial independence
expand parliamentary authority and
strengthen civil liberties in
recognition of the generational shifts
taking place in his country and across
the region the proposed reforms would
lower the qualifying age for
parliamentary candidates to 25 some
Jordanians view these proposals is
stopping short a full constitutional and
electoral reform required by the
creation of party based democracy
nonetheless if enacted they would mark
the most substantial change to Jordan's
governing structure since the adoption
of the Constitution in 1952 King
Abdullah has called for legislative
consideration and adoption of these
proposals to be completed by the year's
end as many of you know the Columbia
global center in Amman was one of the
first global centers ever established at
the University the patron of the center
and in many ways the driving force
behind it is Queen Rania today the
center supports Columbia students and
faculty and building bridges and
scholars to scholars and researchers
artists and educators within Jordan and
across the Middle East and throughout
the globe through this work we are
gaining the intellectual capacity that
will help advance not only Jordans
society but our own in 2009 when the
global center was opened with two
terrific days of programming we were
struck by the way in which the Columbia
community and other students and faculty
from across the region were made to feel
welcome in Jordan
this unusual level of openness and the
embracing attitude we found in Amman and
throughout the country did more than
enrich our experience it confirmed that
the values essential to our vision of
global education are shared by the
people of Jordan it is that very spirit
of openness and constructive dialogue
that defines this campus and the world
leaders forum itself King Abdullah and
Queen Rania have been welcoming host to
columbia today on behalf of our
university I am pleased to be able to
return that hospitality please welcome
His Majesty King Abdullah
miss Valera mama him president Bollinger
friends thank you for your warm welcome
and I am very pleased to visit this
great University once again and I am
delighted to take part in the world
leaders forum especially at a time of
such great significance for my region
all of you gathered here today are
fortunate to belong to the center of
excellence Columbia's intellectual
leadership is matched by its keen
awareness of the challenges facing the
rest of the world and its commitment to
reaching out to peers in my region Lee a
man of few words and plenty of good
deeds is someone who puts his values
front and center of any decision he
makes and has along with the leadership
here work closely as he mentioned with
my wife Rania to establish the
outstanding new Middle East Research
Center scholars and students are
collaborating with Jordanian academics
in Ford leading initiatives and Columbia
graduates are working in vital sectors
across the country and these
partnerships are absolutely essential in
building bridges of understanding
between your country and mine a Native
American Prophet tells us it takes a
thousand voices to tell a single story
today in Arab lands not thousands but
millions of voices are telling the world
their story this story is of aspiration
and struggle of discontent with the past
and dreams of the future three sets of
voices are especially distinctive first
of all other voices of the unemployed
joblessness is a global problem today
but nope
is this problem or cute that in my
region and especially for our young
people the biggest youth cohort in our
history and the majority of our
population today the Middle East has the
highest youth unemployment rate of any
region in the world more than one in
four young people lack good jobs more in
some other places they are saying we
want to see accountability we want
government to respond to our needs and
their voices must be heard the second
set of voices are those of women and
girls they are a vital source of ideas
and energy for our entire region but a
heavy blanket of burdens societal
expectations discrimination prejudice
has stifled their options and
contributions yet women have been at the
forefront of the AG reform movement
their brave faces pictured in the front
lines of Dahlia square and elsewhere
demanding open transparent government
and they're telling us we want to
fulfill our potential as citizens and
leaders and their voices must be heard
the third set of voices are those of the
marginalized these are the old and the
young the men and the women of whatever
sect or social standing who have not
been fully included in social political
or economic life they are the poor and
the underserved the isolated and the
past by and they're telling us give us
social justice and an inclusive role in
our countries with all the rights and
responsibilities they're off and they
too must be heard
the Arab Spring is a new beginning for
our region but it has only been in the
beginning demanding reform is the first
step delivering it is an entirely
different a much more difficult
proposition change is a process not a
position and make no mistake about it
this will not be a homogeneous process
but one that is defined by each country
specific history circumstances and
challenges some Arab countries have a
list of Herculean tasks that most
countries have taken generations to
solve how will they tackle them what are
the answers I cannot say for sure and
I'm not alone in fact one of the
defining features of the past year has
been that of uncertainty the big
unknowns that even the most plugged in
expert on our region our reluctance
predict but here's what I do know for
sure failure to change is a lose-lose
proposition without reform our countries
can deliver less and less of what all
people want a prospering secure future
that everyone has a stake in creating
since assuming the honor of serving
Jordan is position my commitment to
reform has been unwavering and we have
seen some real successes but we have
also witnessed resistance and inertia
the outcomes have not always been what
we wanted and that is not to say that we
in positions of responsibility do not
assume some of the blame and give me a
leader who claims that every decision he
makes has been the right one and i will
give you someone who does not accept his
own humaneness and therefore is not fit
to serve humanity to be sure a turbulent
era has made the road to reform much
tougher to navigate
in 12 short years Jordan has witnessed
an uprising in the West Bank the attacks
of 911 the ensuing war in Afghanistan
the invasion of Iraq which by the way
sending a stream of refugees into Jordan
equivalent to fifty percent of our
population and creating a huge strain on
natural resources and that's not all
there was also the war in Lebanon the
one has de and to make things more
complicated we faced multiple global
economic crises directly affecting
people's lives food energy finance for
growth and jobs today we are where we
are and for me the arab spring brings
the opportunity to create real reform
that we have sought its impetus for
action has offered new openings for
resolve in Jordan we hope the path will
be an evolutionary and consensual one we
want to work together to identify
national priorities and create the
conditions for a better future fair
inclusive and efficient governance more
opportunity and more access to
opportunity in an open growing economy
and progress in development that serves
people's needs this revitalization
process has begun Jordan's aim is
comprehensive homegrown structural
change on multiple fronts political
legislative and economic and to ensure
that momentum is not lost we have said
nature of deadlines and we're holding to
them a core effort addresses our
Constitution which is the cornerstone of
Jordans political life comprehensive
amendments are now moving through
parliament key provisions established at
Independence Constitutional Court and
independent Elections Commission and
safeguards for civil rights and freedoms
and we are reinforcing the separation of
powers among the branches of government
as well as encouraging
medical participation a corresponding
legislation also includes a new election
law and you political parties law and
more reform is not easy but it is going
forward and I am determined to stay the
course but this is the course that must
be shared by all democracy is not just a
system of governance but a way of life
important as they are elections are not
the sole marker of freedom and progress
democratic processes will only have
serve our people if they are viewed in
isolation from constitutional liberties
the guarantee freedom of speech and
religion the rule of law justice and the
protection of minorities these are
values that must define our interactions
as of today our people must start to
assemble not only on the streets but
also around party lines with
well-thought-out political economic and
social platforms and only then can
political life evolve and mature with
participation deliberation and inform
decision making my friends the Arab
Spring is as much a cry to reclaim
dignity as it is to let go of old
systems and regimes and Arab League Glee
has been wounded and left bleeding time
and again by a critical issue that has
fermented anger and frustration over
many decades and that is the
palestinian-israeli conflict today many
in Israel would like to assure
themselves and the rest of you that the
unrest in the Arab Street is unrelated
to them but the sea of change we are
witnessing will forever color the nature
of the relationship between Israel and
its neighbors today Arabs
demanding to be treated as equals and
for Israel not to be treated as the
exception when it comes to international
law and obligations and the
inflexibility of the Israeli stance or
negotiations settlements and Palestinian
statehood is unsustainable as long as
short-term political gains continue to
trump strategic interests Israel will
continue to shortchange its people's
future what is required perhaps is an
Israeli policy spring that will see its
politicians break free from the siege
mentality and engage with its neighbors
as equals a final resolution to this
conflict is long overdue and for time to
time I read my great-grandfather's
reflections on the arbitrary issue to
remind myself just how little has
changed in more than 60 years my father
King Hussein's prayer for peace still
rings in my ears today I selfishly hope
that peace will be ours to witness
because the Arab Spring is not about a
better future it is about a better today
thank you very much
you